GREAT SHOW, TUCKER.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
JUST BREAKING AS WE SPEAK
TONIGHT, WELL, WE CALL HIM
CREEPY AND CRAZY UNCLE JOE BIDEN
FOR A REASON.
NOW HE'S FACING A SECOND
ACCUSATION OF INAPPROPRIATE
TOUCHING.
A ROUGH WEEK FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
IT'S ONLY MONDAY.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
EMBARRASSING HERSELF AGAIN.
BERNIE SANDERS CAN'T ANSWER A
SIMPLE QUESTION ABOUT HIS OWN
POLICIES.
YOU JUST HEARD THE BREAKING
NEWS.
CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE BIDEN IS
FACING A SERIOUS BACKLASH FOR
BEING CREEPY.
WE HAVE THE HANNITY WATCH ON THE
RADICAL 2020 EXTREME DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS.
HE HASN'T FORMALLY ENTERED THE
RACE BUT ALREADY CREEPY UNCLE
JOE IS FACING TWO SEPARATE
ALLEGATIONS OF INAPPROPRIATE
TOUCHING AND MORE.
A CONNECTICUT WOMAN NAMED AMY
LAPOS TOLD THE HARTFORD
NEWSPAPER THAT HE PULLED ME IN
TO RUB NOSES WITH ME.
WHEN HE PULLED ME IN, I THOUGHT
HE WAS GOING TO KISS ME.
THE FIRST ACCUSATION CAME FROM
LUCY SUAREZ.
SHE ENCOUNTERED THE VICE
PRESIDENT BACK STAGE IN 2014 AT
A POLITICAL EVENT.
SHE CLAIMED THAT CRAZY UNCLE JOE
GOT CLOSE TO HER FROM BEHIND,
SNIFFING AND SMELLING HER HAIR
AND PLANTED A KISS ON THE BACK
OF HER HEAD SAYING MY BRAIN
COULDN'T PROCESS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
I WAS EMBARRASSED, SHOCKED AND
CONFUSED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> EVA LONGORIA WAS THERE.
WE WERE LIVED UP NEXT TO THE
STAGE.
EVA WAS IN FRONT OF ME.
JOE BIDEN WAS BEHIND ME.
IT'S THE LAST DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
I'M PREPARING MY REMARKS.
VERY UNEXPECTEDLY AND OUT OF
NOWHERE, I FEEL JOE BIDEN PUT
HIS HANDS ON MY SHOULDERS, GET
UP CLOSE TO ME FROM BEHIND.
LEAN IN.
SMELL MY HAIR.
AND THEN PLANT A SLOW KISS ON
THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
>> Sean: SMELLING SOMEONE'S HAIR
FROM BEHIND, RUBBING NOSES,
KISSING STRANGERS, SOME OF THE
LIPS.
WHO DOES THAT?
APPARENTLY JOE BIDEN AND HE DOES
A LOT.
CREEPY UNCLE JOE IS THE NICKNAME
THAT HE'S EARNED THROUGH THE
YEARS.
AWKWARD TOUCHING, GRABBING,
KISSING, HAIR STROKING AND
SMELLING AND NOSE RUBBING.
THE WOMAN YOU JUST HEARD FROM
TOLD POLITICAL THAT IT'S SO EASY
TO GOOGLE CREEPY BIDEN.
EVERYBODY IS ENTITLED TO DUE
PROCESS AND THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
THE PROP FOR JOE BIDEN IS THERE
WERE DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
PICTURES AND VIDEOS SHOWING
THESE KIND OF ENCOUNTERS.
BIDEN OFFERED A HALF-HEARTED
APOLOGY AND HE SAID HE DOESN'T
BELIEVE HE ACTED
INAPPROPRIATELY.
BRINGS US TO AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
WILL THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HOLD
BIDEN TO THE SAVE BELIEVE-ALL
WOMEN, I BELIEVE, ZERO TOLERANCE
STANDARD THAT THEY HAVE UTILIZED
SO VIGOROUSLY AGAINST
REPUBLICANS.
WHERE ARE ALL THE KAVANAUGH I
BELIEVERS?
SO FAR THE RADICAL SOCIALISTS
THAT DON'T WANT BIDEN TO WIN ARE
COMING OUT AGAINST THE V.P., BUT
THAT'S FOR POLITICAL EXPEDIENCY.
CREEPY UNCLE JOE FANS ARE
SINGING A DIFFERENT TUNE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO MAKE A BIG KERFUFFLE OUT
OF THIS FOR A MAN THAT SPENT THE
LIFE IN HIS SERVICE OF OTHERS IS
WRONG.
WHAT ELSE IS HE TO DO?
LUCY, I'M SORRY I GOT TOO CLOSE
TO YOU.
SERIOUSLY, WHAT ELSE IS HE
SUPPOSED TO DO?
>> IT'S ONE PERSON'S ALLEGATION
FIVE YEARS OLD.
THAT CANNOT NEGATE OR CHANGE JOE
BIDEN'S VERY STRONG RECORD
EMPOWERING WOMEN.
>> HE'S EXTREMELY AFFECTIONATE
IN A SAFE WAY.
BUT ARE WE ALLOWED TO BRING UP
THAT LUCY FLORES IS A HUGE
BERNIE PERSON.
SHE HAS, YOU KNOW, POLITICAL
CONNECTIONS THAT MIGHT BE
COUNTER BIDEN.
IS IT OKAY TO BRING UP THIS
COULD BE POLITICALLY MOTIVATED?
>> NO SURPRISE, SUCKING UP TO
CREEPY UNCLE JOE.
THE SAME MOB THAT TRIED TO RUIN
JUDGE KAVANAUGH'S WILD OVER
30-YEAR-OLD UNCORROBORATED
ALLEGATIONS.
THE ONE THAT GAVE THEM THRILLS
UP THEIR LEG, BARACK OBAMA,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO IT TO
ANY OF THE 2020 CANDIDATES ON
THE EXTREME DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
SIDE.
SO IT WILL BE UP TO US HERE ON
THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE THERE ARE
SO MANY RED FLAGS AND JOE BIDEN
OTHER THAN THE CONSTANT NEED TO
TOUCH AND STROKE AND KISS AND
RUB NOSES.
I'M LET YOU BE THE JUDGE OF THE
PICTURES THAT YOU SEE.
I'M PERSONALLY NOT A FAN OF
PEOPLE RIGHT IN YOUR GRILL.
WE'VE ALL MET PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
SO CLOSE TO YOUR FACE THAT YOUR
NOSES DO TOUCH.
EVEN IF YOU TAKE A STEP BACK,
THEY MOVE IN MORE.
PEOPLE THAT MASSAGE OTHER
PEOPLE.
GO UP AND RUBBING THEIR
SHOULDERS AND WANT TO KISS
PEOPLE ON THE LIPS.
YOU'LL DECIDE.
TONIGHT WE START WITH BIDEN'S
SKETCHY PAST ON RACE IN AMERICA.
THIS WILL BE AN ISSUE FOR HIM.
FOR A DEMOCRATIC PARTY SO
OBSESSED WITH IDENTITY POLITICS,
THIS IS NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7-11 OR
DUNKIN' DONUTS INLESS YOU HAVE A
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
I'M NOT JOKING.
>> WHAT COULDN'T OF A CHANCE
WOULD A NORTHEASTERN LIBERAL
STAND IN THE SOUTH?
>> BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
MY STATE IS A SLAVE STATE A
BORDER STATE, THE EIGHTH LARGEST
POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY OF
BLACKS.
>> ARTICULATE, BRIGHT, CLEAN, A
NICE LOOKING GOOD.
>> ROMNEY WANTS TO LET -- HE
SAID THE FIRST 100 DAYS, HE'S
GOING TO LET THE BIG BANKS WRITE
THEIR OWN RULES.
UNCHAIN WALL STREET.
GOING TO PUT YA'LL BACK IN
CHAINS.
>> FIRST MAINSTREAM AFRICAN
AMERICAN, ARTICULATE, CLEAN.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S STORY BOOK.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SO THE PERSON CURRENTLY POLLING
HIGH NEST THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
IS A MAN THAT CALLED THE
PRESIDENT CLEAN, ARTICULATE AND
STORY BOOK, MAN.
HE BRAGGED THAT HIS HOME STATE
WAS A SLAVE STATE.
YOU CAN'T WORK IN A 7-11 OR
DUNKIN' DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE
AN INDIAN ACCENT.
A YOUNGER SENATOR BIDEN FOUGHT
HARD AGAINST BUSSING FOR SKILLS.
HE DIDN'T WANT INTEGRATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THE CONCEPT OF
BUSSING, WHICH IS THE QUESTION
YOU JUST ASKED OR THE STATEMENT
WITHIN THE QUESTION YOU JUST
ASKED, THAT WE'RE GOING TO
INTEGRATE PEOPLE SO THAT THEY
ALL HAVE THE SAME ACCESS AND
THEY LEARN TO GROW UP WITH ONE
ANOTHER IS A REJECTION OF THE
WHOLE MOVEMENT OF BLACK PRIDE.
>> Sean: THE VERY SAME BIDEN
TOLD THE LOCAL NEWSPAPER THAT I
DON'T FEEL RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SINS OF MY FATHER, GRANDFATHER.
I'LL BE DAMNED IF I FEEL
RESPONSIBLE TO PAY FOR WHAT
HAPPENED 300 YEARS AGO.
TWO DECADES LATER AS CHAIR OF
THE SENATE JUDICIALRY COMMITTEE,
HE PROVIDED OVER JUSTICE
CLARENCE'S CONFIRMATION.
IT WAS A CIRCUIT.
THOMAS CALLED IT A MODERN DAY
LYNCHING.
BIDEN WENT ON AN APOLOGY TOUR
BECAUSE HE OFFERED IT TO ANITA
HILL, THE ACCUSER OF JUSTICE
THOMAS.
HE'S BEEN ON THIS TOUR
APOLOGIZING A WEEK NOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ANITA HILL, PROFESSOR, SHOWED
THE COURAGE OF A LIFETIME.
TALKING ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE
BEING HARASSED BY CLARENCE
THOMAS.
WE KNEW A LOT LESS ABOUT
HARASSMENT BACK THEN, 30 YEARS
AGO.
SHE PAID A TERRIBLE PRICE.
SHE WAS ABUSED THROUGH THE
HEARING.
SHE WAS TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
HER REPUTATION WAS ATTACKED.
I WISH I COULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING.
THERE WAS A REAL AND PERCEIVED
PROBLEM THE COMMITTEE FACED.
A BUNCH OF WHITE GUYS.
I MEAN IT SINCERELY.
>> REMEMBER ANITA HILL DIDN'T
FOLLOW CLARENCE THOMAS AFTER THE
INCIDENTS HAPPENED.
FACTS DON'T WANT TO BE DISCUSSED
AT THIS TIME.
HE'S HAS NOT FORMALLY JUMPED IN
THE RACE.
BIDEN IS ON HIS FIRST APOLOGY
TOUR.
DON'T BE FOOLED, AMTRAK JOE
TRIES TO PAINT HIMSELF AS A
SYMPATHETIC CHAMPION OF THE
PEOPLE.
BEHIND THE SCENES, WE HAVE
DISCOVERED AND WILL REVEAL IN
GREAT DETAIL, SHADY, SWAMMY
BEHAVIOR.
BACK IN 2014, WHILE JOE BIDEN
WAS THE VICE PRESIDENT, HIS SON
HUNTER ACCEPTED A BOARD SEAT ON
UKRAINE'S, ONE OF THE LARGEST
OIL AND GAS COMPANIES OWNED BY
UKRAINIAN OLIGARCH FACING
INTERNATIONAL MONEY LAUNDERING
ALLEGATIONS.
NATURALLY THIS RAISED SERIOUS
ETHICAL QUESTIONS AND SOME
SCORNED FROM THE LEFT CORN TO
AUTHOR PETER SCHWEITZER AND HIS
BOOK "SECRET EMPIRES" WHILE
HUNTER BIDEN WAS WORKING IN THE
UKRAINIAN OIL COMPANY,
SUSPICIOUS FOREIGN TRANSACTIONS
FLOWED TO AN ACCOUNT USED BY
HUNTER BIDEN, INCLUDING A
MULTIMILLION DOLLARS DEPOSIT
FROM THAT COMPANY.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS ALL OCCURRED
WHILE HIS FATHER WAS VICE
PRESIDENT.
SERVING AS ONE OF THE KEY POINT
PERSONS FOR THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ANTI-CORRUPTION
METHODS IN UKRAINE.
ANY OF THIS SOUND FAMILIAR?
EERILY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
LEARNED ABOUT THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION?
A LOT TO UNPACK HERE.
WE'LL HAVE FULL COVERAGE OF THIS
STORY IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS
AHEAD.
SAME STORY WITH CHINA.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HYPOCRISY
FROM THE LEFT.
CLINTON, BIDEN.
DEMOCRATS GET A FREE PASS.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
CONSERVATIVES, DEMONIZED WITH OR
WITHOUT EVIDENCE.
AND BY THE WAY, HIS SON WHILE
DOING THE DEALS IN CHINA AND
UKRAINE -- WE'LL GET TO CHINA
TOMORROW -- HE WAS ON AIR FORCE
2 WITH HIS FATHER.
HE HAD A FREE TRIP TO DO THE
DEALS.
LOOK AT THE COMMONWEALTH OF
VIRGINIA.
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR, ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THEY ADMITTED TO
DRESSING UP IN BLACK FACE.
BEING RACIST IN THE 80s.
ARE THEY FACING IN I
CONSEQUENCES?
NOPE.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF IT WAS A
REPUBLICAN?
THERE'S LIEUTENANT JUSTIN
FAIRFAX.
TWO SEPARATE WOMEN HAVE MADE
SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS, SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND VIOLENT RAPE.
YET TO THIS DAY, THE I
BELIEVERS, DEMOCRATS IN
VIRGINIA, THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING
TO HOLD FAIRFAX ACCOUNTABLE AND
DEAFENING SILENCE FROM THE
PEOPLE SAYING I BELIEVE IN THE
KAVANAUGH CASE.
SO THE PARTY THAT TELLS YOU AND
US TO BELIEVE WOMEN, ALL WOMEN,
WELL, THEY DON'T SEEM CAPABLE OF
ACCUSING ONE OF THEIR OWN.
UNLESS THEY WANT TO BEAT THEM IN
A PRIMARY.
THAT'S WHY LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
FAIRFAX, THE FIRST ACCUSER, WAS
COMPELLED TO SPEAK OUT EARLIER
TODAY.
WE HAVE THE TAPE.
>> HE'S PUSHING DOWN, PUSHING
DOWN.
I COULDN'T HOLD MY NECK UP.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
I HONESTLY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
THE NEXT THING I KNOW, MY HEAD
IS IN HIS CROTCH.
>> SEXUAL ASSAULT IS AN EPIDEMIC
TAKING PLACE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
EVERY DAY.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT TO HAPPEN TO
JUSTIN FAIRFAX?
WHY ARE YOU COMING FORWARD?
>> I WANT HIM TO RESIGN.
>> IN THE COMING MONTHS AND
TOMORROW, WE'LL GET TO SEE
WHETHER THE PARTY OF IDENTITY
POLITICS IS WILLING TO HOLD
THEMSELVES TO THE SAME STANDARDS
THEY PLACE ON EVERYBODY ELSE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HOLD OUR
BREATH.
BUT THAT IS YOUR RADICAL CROP OF
EXTREME 2020 DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS THAT WANT TO BE
PRESIDENT AND HOW THEY WILL
SHAMELESSLY DEPLOY THE SAME OLD
TIRED FEAR TACTICS AND IDENTITY
POLITICS ALWAYS AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE, ROBERT FRANCIS
BETO O'ROURKE KICKED OFF HIS
CAMPAIGN IN EL PASO.
FREQUENTLY IMPLYING THAT WALLS
ARE IMMORAL.
WE SHOULD OPEN THE BORDER, TEAR
DOWN THE EXISTING WALLS THERE.
ROBERT FRANCIS LIVES IN A
FANTASY WORLD.
THERE IS A SERIOUS CRISIS
TONIGHT AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
AGAIN.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
EXPERIENCING ONE MORE TIME A
MASSIVE SURGE.
ANOTHER HUGE CARAVAN ON THE WAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS CUT AID OVER
THE WEEKEND TO THREE CENTRAL
AMERICAN COUNTRIES WHERE THE
CARAVANS ARE ORIGINATING.
HE'S THREATENING TO CLOSE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IN MEXICO IF
MEXICO DOES NOT DO THEIR JOB AND
STOP THE CARAVAN FROM MARCHING
NORTH.
WE'LL HAVE MORE COMING UP
TONIGHT.
FIRST, ANOTHER RADICAL 2020
CANDIDATE WHO JUST PREDICTED
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
DIE IF PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATENS
TO FIX, KEEP YOUR DOCTOR, PAY
LESS.
MILLIONS LOST THEIR DOCTORS AND
EVERYBODY PAID MORE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TRUMP HAS AN IDEA ON
HEALTHCARE.
HIS IDEA IS TO THROW 32 MILLION
AMERICANS OFF THE HEALTH
INSURANCE THEY HAVE.
DOING AWAY WITH INSURANCE FOR
KIDS THAT ARE 26 YEARS OF AGE
THAT ARE YOUNGER AND ON THEIR
PARENT'S PLANS.
DOING AWAY WITH THE PROTECTION
THAT THE ACA HAS FOR
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
THAT MEANS IF YOU HAVE CANCER,
HEART DISEASE, DIABETES.
IF TRUMP GETS HIS WAY, THE COST
OF HEALTH INSURANCE FOR YOU WILL
BE SO HIGH THAT MANY PEOPLE
LITERALLY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO A
FORD IT.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WILL DIE.
>> Sean: ACTUALLY, IT'S
SOCIALISM THAT HAS KILLED
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
AND LED TO MORE POVERTY AND
SUFFERING.
EVERY PROMISE A SOCIALIST
COUNTRY MAKES IS BROKEN,
UNREALISTIC.
THE GREATEST STANDARD OF LIVING,
THE GREATEST COUNTRY THAT GOD
GAVE MAN, THE UNITED STATES
BASED ON FREEDOM AND
OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE WANT
TO GET HER ILLEGALLY.
THEY HAVE WHAT WE WANT AND WE
TAKE FOR GRANTED.
BERNIE SANDERS, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, THEY DON'T SEEM
TO HAVE THE BEST GRASP ON
HISTORY.
FOR EXAMPLE, TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
HISTORICAL ANALYSIS FROM
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ FROM
OVER THE WEEKEND.
THIS IS PRICELESS.
>> WHEN OUR PARTY WAS BOLDEST,
THE TIME OF THE NEW DEAL, THE
GREAT SOCIETY, THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT AND SO ON, WE HAD AND
CARRIED SUPER MAJORITIES IN THE
HOUSE, THE SENATE, WE CARRIED
THE PRESIDENCY.
THEY HAD TO AMEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES TO MAKE SURE ROOSEVELT
DIDN'T GET RE-ELECTED.
>> FDR DIED IN 1945, TWO YEARS
BEFORE PRESIDENTIAL TERM LIMITS
WERE IMPLEMENTED.
YOU'D THINK A PERSON -- REMEMBER
SHE WAS GOING TO BE SWORN IN TO
OFFICE.
SOMEBODY SWORN TO UPHOLD AND
PROTECT THE U.S. CONTUSION WOULD
UNDERSTAND THE AMENDMENTS TO OUR
U.S. CONSTITUTION.
MAYBE THAT'S TOO MUCH TO EXPECT